a finite game is known players fixed
rules and agreed upon objective football
baseball there's always a beginning
middle and an end and if there is a
winner necessarily they have to be
losers um then you have infinite gains
infinite games are defined as known and
unknown players which means new players
can join anytime and you don't
necessarily know who all the other
players are the rules are changeable
which means every player can play
however they want and the objective is
to perpetuate the game to stay in the
game as long as possible companies come
and go and yet the game continues with
you without you and there's no such
thing as winning nobody wins business it
doesn't exist but if you listen to the
language of too many leaders becomes
abundantly clear they don't always know
the game they're playing in they talk
about being number one or being the best
or beating their competition based on
what you know and I love it when
Executives come to me and say you know
we are number one and I always say for
now the idea of building a company that
can survive every single employee in
this room after you've long gone and
that that company remains true to its
purpose is a very very powerful thing
the Walt Disney Company the purpose that
Disney founded they've gone through you
know trials and tribulations for sure
for the most part when they are at their
natural best they hearken back to their
founding purpose and I love that you
know you ask me is it essential I mean
depends on what kind of company you want
to run if you want a company that can
continue to innovate and set the course
for what business should look like
Define what Innovation looks like in
your industry then build that company
but if you want to build a company that
just sucks the life out of people who
work there and it does damage to the
communities in which we work all in the
name of short-term gains you can build
that company too it'll come at a much
steeper cost in terms of Love loyalty et
cetera et cetera so hey it's Evan
Carmichael and I make these videos
because
first business I struggled to believe in
myself I quit on my business partner and
the thing that saved me was watching the
successful stories of entrepreneurs they
gave me the inspiration to keep going as
well as the strategies of what to do and
quite honestly I still need their
stories and motivation today as well so
today let's live your best believe life
and learn how to change our lives with
Simon signic enjoy
rule number two is listen more so
listening is a trust building exercise
right if you've if you're in a Rel take
it down to a personal relationship if
you've been in if you've ever had a
romantic relationship it's a loved one
right
um
um making someone feel heard
doesn't mean you're wrong saying sorry
doesn't mean you're wrong it just means
you take accountability for your for
your actions and I think it is important
that when somebody objects to
vaccination that we don't demonize or
villainize them but we attempt to
hear them make them feel heard doesn't
mean we have to agree but they have to
feel heard and you know they'll
listening is not hearing the words
you know it's making the other person
feel that they were heard it's it's it
we don't get to decide when when hearing
has happened when listening is that they
do and and by the way it's not 100
successful either you know because some
people are just hell-bent on and but
that's a minority
and so I think the exercise of sitting
down with people and say tell me tell me
what's what you're going through tell me
what you're afraid of I I want to
understand because we're trying to make
everyone safe I I wanna I wanna hear
what what your thing is and let them
tell their story we have no answers
we're not there to object we're not
there to react we're not that to fix or
tell them that they're wrong women are
better than this than men
um uh
and I think that has to happen and it
can happen simultaneously they are not
mutually exclusive
um I'll give you one one example
which is I have a friend who uh
refused to get vaccinated
and I sat down with her and I said
tell me tell me your reasoning
right she goes well
um this new technology like I don't
wanna we don't know it hasn't been out
long enough like we don't know so what I
hear is fear of the unknown
okay I go go on and she I let her talk
and say her thing and explain all the
things and I and then and I simply said
so you're afraid of the MRNA technology
right yes and I want them screwing with
my DNA
I said well just so you know it's 20
year old technology but then I found
something I could agree with her but but
you're right
it is the first time it's been
commercialized you're absolutely right
that's the first time we've put it in
the market so I affirmed her fear
and then I said do you get flu shots
every year she goes I do I said okay
Johnson and Johnson is a good
old-fashioned flu shot it's a different
technology it's not mRNA so I you're 100
right if you're afraid of of the new
technology don't get modern or Pfizer
but Johnson and Johnson is it's just
like a flu shot it's the same old Tech
and she went it is when it is she went
and got a modern shot
[Laughter]
because
to be heard because most of her
friends when she said I'm not getting
vaccinated yelled at her told her she
was stupid told her she's an idiot told
her she's letting her friends down told
her she's making other people sick told
that she's a risk to society
that doesn't make somebody's mind open
up all I did was let her feel heard
I think we do we can't we have to do
that rule number three is bring your why
to life what is your why and has it
evolved over the last decade at all
uh so my why
is to inspire people to do the things
that Inspire them so together each of us
can change our world for the better
and it's why I wake up every morning
every day it is the greatest compliment
someone can pay me when they say to me
that was inspiring or you were inspiring
like that feeds me
you know
um and the interesting thing about a why
is because it is not it is objective
a why is the sum total of how we were
raised it's born out of the patterns and
the lessons we learned from our parents
from our teachers when we're young and
our Y is fully formed by the time we're
in our mid to late teens and you only
have one wife for the rest of your life
it doesn't change
you have you are who you are based on
how you were raised now you may not be
acting as your true self you know people
say that to us all the time you know
it's like I don't know who you are
anymore you know but when you are at
your natural best your why is front and
center but we're not always acting at
our natural best and sometimes we make
decisions out of selfishness we shake we
take the job that pays us that offers us
the most money and turn down the one to
work for somebody who would probably be
a better Mentor you know we do these
things all the time and so you know can
you tweak the words of your why of
course you know but that's that's
semantics
um can we find better ways to to bring a
why to life yes that's the evolution but
the why itself is fixed when you talk
about the why being influenced by the
things that happened in our life our
experiences are upbringing
does that mean that our trauma can
influence our Wife For Better or For
Worse always for better always for
better yeah a y is always positive
um uh and I'll I'll give you a real life
example of somebody's wide discovery
that I did and you know one of the
things I do when I do somebody's white
Discovery I ask them about you know
happy experiences when they were kids
and this person said I didn't have a
very happy childhood I had a really bad
childhood
and I said okay so tell me tell me a bad
memory then you know
and she talked about a lot of abuse in
the household in a very abusive
alcoholic father who had beat
her mother and the kids and she told a
story of a repeated pattern of when the
father would be drunk and come looking
for the kids that she'd be hiding in the
cupboard
protecting her brother with her arms
wrapped around him so to Shield her
brother
and she goes through this whole story
and at the end
I pointed out to her that she's a
protector that in the in these traumatic
experiences it was her instinct to to
protect her baby brother and she's lived
her life if you look at all of the times
that she's really thrived and where
she's her her best self she's usually in
a in a position of protection of other
of other people and that's where she
finds joy in taking care of other people
and so the the experiences mold us into
who we are
um and the effects you know the impact
will be positive regardless of where it
comes from so yeah I mean the horrible
childhood that made her a wonderful
human being also to make sure you're
actually taking action after watching
this video I've designed a special free
worksheet just for this video the
worksheet will highlight all the Lessons
Learned in this video as well as pull
out our three favorite learnings and
quotes that will inspire you to actually
do something the worksheet will also
give you space to write down what your
key takeaways are and your specific plan
of action to make sure you're getting
results if you want the worksheet
designed specifically for this video
absolutely for free there's a link in
the description below go click on it and
start building the momentum in your life
and your business I'll see you there
rule number four is do things that make
you better infinite mindset is I may win
or lose this game I may win or lose this
transaction and there'll be another one
and another one and another one and
another one and the goal is not to win
this one the goal is to be better and
better and better and better and better
and what happens is you win more often
yeah so I I uh see and where I struggle
with that honestly is I want to crush it
every time yeah of course of course
you're a highly competitive A type
personality I get it yeah
um
um but if that's all you do you you're
not going to be in the game
professionally I know I can I've been in
a long time but this is my point in
infinite in the infinite game the
infinite game the infinite mindset is
about having the strength the will and
the resources which means we is I really
still enjoy this industry
and the resources I got the money to
stay in the game if you run out of will
you run out of resources you find a
different line of work right the goal is
not to win every game the goal is to
stay in the game as long as possible and
you're more likely to stay in the game
as long as possible if you're enjoying
it and if you're making money
so uh but like I said think of those
agents who are better than you whether
they're better marketers or better
salesperson or they have they get more
recommendations and again you don't have
to like them you have to thank them and
study them and learn what they're doing
as I said because their strengths are
revealed revealing to your weaknesses
and sometimes partner with them because
you're actually stronger together
um but hating them is stupid right
all it does is make you cut focus on
them rather than focus on yourself all
it does is make you focus and and sit
around with your friends and be like but
they don't do this and they well you're
not doing any of that either you know so
it puts all your focus in all the wrong
places
it's like you know what it's like uh if
the any skiers out there
if you ski through trees
every skier knows this if you say don't
hit a tree don't hit a tree don't hit a
tree you hit a tree
because all you're doing is looking at
trees
where when you're skiing to be treason
you say follow the path follow the path
follow the path you don't hit a tree
because you're only looking at the path
so your mindset is if all you're doing
is focusing on them then you're good
you're hitting trees is what you're
doing you're focusing all the things
that make you weak rather than focusing
on all the things that'll make you
better well number five is be truthful a
term that's been overused in business
this concept of authenticity right all
that authenticity means is the things
you say and the things you do you
actually believe
and there's a lot of room for cynicism
in the in the in the uh financial
advisor World
um because every financial advisor says
the right thing I'm here to help you I'm
here to help you find your nest egg to
achieve your financial goals and blah
blah blah blah blah blah every financial
advisor I've ever met tells me the same
thing but then the way they make me feel
not always consistent where they may say
the right things but then they're not
actually listening to the things that I
want I can feel that they're just trying
to hammer a product
um they're not actually trying to do
what I what I ex what I talk about but
rather I can feel the feel that they
have an agenda that they're pushing
something on me and so you know we're
highly attuned social animals we can
tell the difference and if somebody's
going to put their agenda their uh uh
commission their interests first then
stop saying I'm here to help you and
achieve your financial goals because I
care about you
stop saying those words I don't have I
don't have a problem with somebody being
selfishly minded if they approach their
business just stop pretending that
you're not
because the ones that truly do care will
be way more creative if they say I'm
truly trying to help you they'll be
offering advice and forwarding articles
that have nothing to do with with the
financial tools that you can buy from me
I might send you an article about you
know your teenagers and and screen time
for example because you because that's
one of the things you're concerned about
and I'm here to help you live a better
life like I may be more curious about
all of the aspects of about helping you
of which some are the things that I can
deliver on within Financial advice and
some Financial tools so I think I think
if you got into this business to help
people then help people rule number six
is be a good leader if you have somebody
in a leadership position who who
literally doesn't respect uh diversity
and and inclusion
um you know the question is why are they
in a leadership position
um uh uh so it's it's a bit of a loaded
question now I understand the challenges
you know if you do things with intention
if there's an intention to go out and
find something you know you're more
likely to find it and I also think what
what companies with with resources can
do is build their own bench which is go
to universities you know invest in the
programs that will train the people
train uh in this case as you said some
gender diversity so that they have the
skills and then uh and offer them the
potential for jobs when they come
through the the program so you set them
up in other words build your own bench
because I've heard this from companies
before which is you know we'd love to
but the talent's not there you know so
go build the bench if you have a
long-term approach to this stuff it's
not about solving a problem in a month
you know it's about solving a problem
um so that it's sticky so it's not just
a reaction but rather it becomes
inculcated and built in into the fabric
of the company
um and and I go back to leadership
training again
um which is what good leaders recognize
is that a diverse Workforce brings
diversity of points of view if everybody
looks like me went to a similar school
as me you know uh was was brought up
like me
um then we're all going to have kind of
similar points of view on some of the
challenges we face but when we have
people with different racial um
backgrounds or or different or different
genders we you know some people grew up
in Europe versus America or Rich versus
poor they bring entirely New
Perspectives based on their world view
to a problem and the more diverse
perspectives we have on any challenge it
means the more options we have to solve
that problem and this is not surprising
to me that when you say we have a more
when we have more diversity we're
actually better at the thing we're
trying to do that makes perfect perfect
sense and so I think one of the things
to do is for Senior Management to to
hammer away that this is essential for
us it's important for us
um and that uh uh that leaders will are
going to be expected to embrace this
um that we're going to be judging our
leaders and their ability to do this to
build
um uh more diverse teams and to go out
into the marketplace to before before
these some of these young people start
looking for jobs and start training them
in the skills that you want and setting
them up it goes to what we said before
which is we want to make you a whole
person we'll give you some of the
technical skills and some of the human
skills and then when you join us you're
going to be a better prepared uh a
person a better prepared employee to
join to join our team because we've
already set you up for success with hard
skills and human skills and rule number
seven the last one before some very
special bonus Clips is live in Balance I
mean the technology is great you know
it's lots of fun very helpful makes a
lot of things easy
but like anything in the world there's
um there is too much of a good thing you
know
um and I think one of the things we
don't talk about is what is the balance
of technology in our lives and I would
argue that for many of us it's out of
balance
we know
that the chemical dopamine is released
whenever we get a bing Buzz flasher beat
from our phone or email right so
dopamine is the exact same chemical
that's released in alcohol nicotine and
gambling right in other words it can be
addictive if left unbalanced a little
alcohol is great
too much alcohol not so great gambling
is fun too much gambling really bad
right technology is wonderful too much
technology can be very destructive and
destroy our relationships like all
addictions destroy our relationships
right and so what the one thing we're
not considering is what is the right
balance if you wake up in the morning
and you check your phone before you say
good morning to your spouse that's a
problem right if you have Phantom beeps
that's a problem that comes from
something right if you find yourself
incapable of getting through a day
without
needing to check that's a problem right
now where it gets really dangerous is
with
kids millennials
some of them aren't kids anymore right
um so almost all alcoholics on the
planet
discovered alcohol when they were
children
when we're very very young the only
thing we need is the approval of our
parents right when we go through
adolescence we now need approval from
our peers frustrating for our parents
very important for us because it allows
us to acculturate outside of our
immediate families into the larger group
right
very stressful time and we're supposed
to learn in this time of anxiety to rely
on our friends to reach out to our
friends for help that's we're supposed
to learn some people quiet by accident
discover alcohol
and that they learned the numbing
effects of dopamine actually help them
get through the stress of adolescents
this connection unfortunately becomes
hardwired and so for the rest of their
lives when they face any kind of
financial career or social stress they
don't turn to a person they turn to the
bottle right now we have age
restrictions on alcohol
cigarettes and gambling because we know
that an immature mind is not yet strong
enough or mature enough to deal with the
powers of these addicting
chemicals these addictive chemicals
right so we put an age limit we have no
such age limit for age restriction on
social media or cell phones
right so ostensibly what we've done is
we've thrown open the liquor cabinet and
we've said to our adolescents hey I know
this whole adolescent thing is really
stressful so here's the Vodka take as
much as you need that's basically what
we've done and so what we have is an
entire generation that's growing up
addicted
and like all addicts they haven't
learned the skill set of when they
suffer stress to turn to a person
what they do is they turn to the device
and what that only does is increase
senses of isolation and loneliness and
can actually destroy relationships we've
all had the experience where you're with
somebody walking down the street in a
meeting out for dinner whatever and they
pull out their phone and you feel like
an idiot right or when you're talking to
them and they're going uh-huh uh-huh
you're sort of like what am I what's the
point of this now take an entire
generation that has no memory of a time
before the device we at least can
reference times before cell phones and
internet and social media we at least
have a point of reference they don't
so this is their normal but that's how
they feel so you have an entire
generation growing up with addiction and
an increased sense of loneliness and
isolation we're already seeing the
results we're seeing increased rates of
suicide amongst this generation we're
seeing increased rates of accidental
deaths due to overdoses amongst this
generation we're seeing increased
numbers of mass homicides largely
performed by this generation
school shootings yeah over 70
perpetrated by kids born after the year
1984. we
um schools universities are now dealing
with numbers they've never dealt with
before of kids requesting leaves of
absence due to depression
we're already seeing it
right we're seeing the effects of
loneliness and isolation we're seeing it
and yet we're not reacting to it we're
not doing anything about it
right
and parents are a lot to blame for this
because parents there are some schools
who want to restrict phones in schools
and it's the parents who demand that
they keep their phones in case of
emergencies
seriously seriously when was the last
time the cell phone was used for an
emergency what time are you coming home
what time should we pick you up and if
there is an emergency you call the
office and they know what classroom the
kid's in and in five minutes they'll
bring the kid to talk to you on the
phone like the old way worked just fine
remember we talked before about
Innovation it has to solve a real human
problem what human problem exactly did
we solve by compressing the five minute
time frame we added to the problem we
didn't solve it so that's one huge
problem so combine that with the facts
you have a an addictive generation that
doesn't have the skill set to ask for
help combined with the fact that they're
so good at Facebook and Instagram
they're good at putting filters on
everything so they're good at showing
you how smart and strong they are these
kids who commit suicide you go look at
their Instagrams you would have no clue
that they were depressed because they're
happy and they're star athletes right
you'd have no clue because they're
really good so when we say silly things
like my door is always open
you're assuming they have the courage to
come in
combined with the fact that they're
subject largely not all but too many to
a failed parenting strategy because
their parents told them they were
special they could have anything they
wanted they could be anything they want
they got medals for coming in last which
by the way we know doesn't work it
devalues the metal for the one who comes
in first and the one who came in last it
makes them feel stupid because they know
they didn't deserve it right the kids
got into honors classes not because they
deserved it but because the parents
complained and some of them got good
grades not because they earned them but
because the teachers didn't want to deal
with the parents
and then the kids graduate college and
they get a job and in an instant they
find out they're not special
they don't get anything for coming at
last the parents can't get them a
promotion and you can't have whatever
you want just because you want it
and in an instant their entire
self-image is shattered and so you have
an entire generation growing up with
lower self-confidence than previous
generations so you have lower
self-confidence than previous
generations combined with an inability
to ask for help with things that you're
struggling with and you turn to social
media or device you keep checking you
keep checking you count your legs you
count your legs you count your followers
you count your followers and if somebody
unfriends you oh my God it's trauma
right the way they break up with each
other is they just ghost each other just
cut each other out and stop returning to
text returning texts and returning
vocals because they don't have the skill
set to say hey it's not working out it's
not me it's you right there's no closure
on things right
combined with the fact there's an
institutionalized impatience
so they've grown up in a world of
instant gratification you want to buy
something you go on Amazon it shows up
the next day
you want to get in touch with someone
you don't leave a message on their
machine and wait four hours for them to
get the message you just text them and
they get back to you immediately you
want to watch a movie you just log on
and watch it you don't have to check
movie times right everything happens
instantly you want to get a date swipe
right you don't even have to muster up
the courage to go and be like hey you
know you don't have to there you go got
a date right
and so the problem is they're accused of
being entitled I don't think they're
entitled at all not at all I think
they're impatient
I keep meeting these fantastic smart
driven ambitious idealistic fantastic
kids who graduated school they got a job
they want to make an impact on the world
and I go up to them and say how is it
going and they say
I think I'm gonna quit
I'm like why
they're like
I'm not making an impact I'm like you've
been here eight months
and it's as if it's as if they see the
summit of a mountain does that as if
they're standing at the foot of a
mountain they can see the summit they
can see the thing they want I want to
make an impact what they don't see is
the mountain
large immovable object you can go up
fast you can go up slow I don't care but
the still amount what they don't
understand is that life
that relationships and career
fulfillment are a journey there's no app
for that I got nothing you've got to go
through the slow plotting annoying
Meandering process called career in life
but if they don't get it in eight months
they go look for it somewhere else they
don't get it they go go look for it's
impatience and because they don't have
the skill set to ask for help and
because they feel lonely it compounds
and compounds so then we dump them in
office environments that are built on
theories from the 80s and 90s that
prioritizes a number before a person and
no one really cares about their
confidence and their personal growth
they're just numbers on a spreadsheet
and so they enter Work cultures that
don't help them and the problem is
they're entering the workforce at a
deficit I hear from kids they tell me
that they struggle to form deep
meaningful relationships and the
companies don't care
and so it's destructive to them as
individuals But ultimately it'll hurt
the companies because more and more
Millennials are entering the workforce
I believe to your point about solution
that now the responsibility on companies
is even greater than it's ever been
before to take care of its people
because if the environments in which we
are asking our youngest workers to work
in
isn't built to help them
I can't even imagine what the suicide
and and homicide and just the rates of
depression
you know an accidental death due to
overdose are going to look like in the
future it's going to reach epidemic
proportions it's already the the
statistics are already alarming and yet
nobody's sounding any alarm Bells
parents have to intervene we have to
stop giving our kids free access to
social media and phones at Young ages
they are not ready for it their minds
cannot cope with the dopamine balance is
fine you you can give a kid a phone but
they can't use it in their bedroom they
can't have it at the dinner table they
can't take it to school they can only
have it up to a certain hour and you
take it away they're children you can
take the phone away
we've got to intervene as parents but as
companies we now have to deal with the
influx of kids that are coming into our
companies with addiction
watch I see it all the time walk through
any office you'll see the older
employees have their phones on the sides
of their computers as they're working
you'll see the youngest employees have
their phones face up in front of their
keyboards between their arms as they're
working this is how they work and the
statistics the science is alarming they
did experiments on mice where they they
did the multitasking they put flashing
lights to mimic going from the computer
to the cell phone the computer to the
cell phone to the TV the mice that were
exposed to the changing lights it took
them three times longer to solve a maze
than the mice that weren't and the
damage was permanent
it didn't improve when they stopped the
lights and Leadership now is even more
important yeah and the leaders now are
even more irresponsible you are
responsible for the lives of human
beings and some of these human beings
are your children so okay you buy the
CEO who thinks all the stuff that I talk
about is craziness and you don't have
time to make these changes this is I
hear we don't have time it's a war out
there I've actually heard Executives
tell me that it's a war out there I
don't have time for this leadership
stuff
I know guys who go to war and I'll tell
you it's not a war what you're going
through you know you Tinker with money
it's not a war you do have time for this
and if it's really that way then what
were you doing when it wasn't a war it's
even more it's what an indictment that
in peaceful times when times were good
that you weren't focusing on this stuff
right but my point is is a lot of these
Executives have children
of this age working at other companies
and my question is would you like those
other companies would you like those
other Executives to care about the
growth of your child
the confidence of your child the Career
Success of your child
would you like those other companies to
help your kids learn the skills of
social interaction the ability to ask
for and receive help would you like
their jobs to give that to them
at the example do it for other people's
children every single employee 100 is
someone someone's daughter
a hundred percent and if you want
someone to take responsibility for the
life of your children in their company
then why don't we start taking
responsibly for the lives of the
children in our company
I talk to so many smart fantastic
ambitious idealistic hard-working kids
and they're right out of college they're
in their entry level jobs and I'll ask
them how's it going and they'll say
I think I'm gonna quit
and I'm like why they say to me I'm not
making an impact
I'm like you know you've been here eight
months right
they treat the sense of fulfillment or
even love like it's a scavenger hunt
like it's something you look for my
Millennial friends they've gone through
so many jobs they're either getting
fired I mean it was Mutual
or they're quitting
because they're not making an impact or
they're not finding the thing they're
looking for they're not feeling
fulfilled as if it's a scavenger hunt
love
a job you find Joy from is not something
you discover it's not like I Found Love
here it is I found a job I love that's
not how it works both of those things
require hard work you are in love
because you work very hard every single
day of your life to stay in love
you find a job that brings you ultimate
Joy because you work hard every single
day to serve those around you and you
maintain that Joy it's not a discovery
but the problem is the sense of
impatience
it's as if an entire generation is
standing at the foot of a mountain they
know exactly what they want they can see
the summit what they can't see is the
mountain
this large
immovable object that doesn't mean you
have to do your time that's not what I'm
talking about take a helicopter climb I
don't care but there's still a mountain
life career fulfillment relationships
are journeys
the problem is this entire generation
has an institutionalized sense of
impatience and do they have the patience
to go on the journey to maintain love to
feel fulfilled or do they just quit and
on to the next dump it onto the next
ghost and on to the next and by the way
ghosting
means the lack of skill to have a
confrontation
you date somebody for six months eight
months
and then just stop replying
just delete them from everything
now for the person who's doing the
ghosting oh that's certainly easier than
a confrontation but the person on the
receiving end of the ghosting it's like
there's a death there's suddenly shunned
there's Panic they call out they're
worrying they call out their word they
think it's you they think it's them do
you have any idea the destruction that
we reap on people by ghosting them
and then because there's the lack of
social skills to call out and ask for
help they internalize and it makes them
feel awful to the point at the worst
they will kill themselves slightly one
level down they'll get depressed but the
lowest level that we can hope for is
they will go through life and I'm not
talking about ghosting I'm talking an
entire generation that if we don't fix
this we'll go through life where
everything's just fine my friendships
are fine my work is fine you know same
old same old nothing's ever amazing
and the scavenger hunt continues
and then you go to the fourth
observation the most egregious of all of
them environment
we're taking a generation that has lower
self-esteem we're taking a generation
that has a lack of coping mechanisms to
deal with stress we're dealing with a
generation that wants all those things
fixed immediately and we're placing them
in work environments that values money
more than people
do you know that most of the business
philosophies most of the business
theories that we Embrace and see a
standard today are not standard there
are theories left over from the 80s and
90s
the concept of shareholders Supremacy
was a theory proposed in the late 1970s
it was popularized in the 80s and 90s
the concept of using mass layoffs to
balance the books did not exist in the
United States prior to the 1980s
it did not exist
it became popular in the 80s and 90s
the 80s and 90s were boom years
anyone could make money relative peace a
Kinder gentle or cold war and so all of
the business theories that were put
forth were very very selfish and all
about enriching ourselves
and they worked for those times but
these times are different these are not
peaceful times
these are not boom years this is there's
globalization in the internet which has
now made everything vastly more
complicated and those theories do not
work anymore worse they're having side
effects
it's really bad
because what we do is we destroy
corporate cultures
the idea of using mass layoffs can you
imagine sending someone home and saying
I'm sorry
I can no longer provide for our family
because the company missed its arbitrary
projections this year
that's what we're doing that's like a
coach prioritizing the needs of the fans
over the needs of the players hoping to
build a great team
it doesn't work
we dismantled things like the
glass-steagall Act glass-steagall was
passed after the Great Depression to
prevent another Great Depression from
happening it would dismantled in the 80s
and the 90s in the name of a prophet
okay do you know how many stock market
crashes we had between the Great
Depression and the dismantling of
glass-steagall
the answer is
zero
and since they dismantled glass-steagall
we had 87 the.com crash 2008. we've had
three stock market crashes because we've
moved the safety mechanisms that prevent
stock market crashes from happening all
in the name of individual advancement
and profit and these are the corporate
cultures we've built
corporate cultures that value numbers
over people and they are not standard
business practices they are new and they
are broken and they are dangerous and
we're asking a young wonderful ambitious
amazing generation that needs us to work
in these environments
whether we like it or not
we have to take responsibility for that
bad hand that you've been dealt
it is up to the companies to create an
environment in which you can build your
self-confidence it is up to the
companies to create an environment
in which you can learn coping mechanisms
and learn how to build strong close
relationships with people with whom you
work
that you will eventually love and
sacrifice to see that they gain
it is in these environments that we will
learn the patience and the hard work
that it takes to find fulfillment in our
lives to find a sense of purpose a sense
of joy
yes it's all fine and good that my
generation and older Generations say to
you things like well you're the Future
Leaders we're the leaders now
we're the ones in control of the
corporate environments now
and we're making your lives worse
I don't want you to jump from job to job
to job to job you will never find what
you're looking for it's not a scavenger
hunt I don't want you to go from
relationship to relationship to
relationship what I want you to do is
stand up and demand that the places in
which you work lead you properly
nobody wants to wake up in the morning
and be managed we want to wake up in the
morning and be led and we have a total
leadership crisis in America politics is
just the mirror reflection we get the
politicians we deserve
We're The Divided ones we're the selfish
ones we're the broken ones we're the
ones who would sooner sacrifice somebody
else so that we may gain it's us
and until we're willing to do the hard
work of repairing the world around us
our country our politics our businesses
will not fix here's what I've learned
about mentorship mentorship is not
something you ask somebody to do like
will you be my friend it doesn't work
like that
um when you find somebody you get along
with you share values you share beliefs
you spend time with them you get to know
them you develop trust you take us
You're vulnerable with them you open up
to them and you discover that you become
friends it's what happens you start off
as simply acquaintances
um in in my experience mentorship is
exactly the same there were people who
were much more experienced than me who
had wisdom that I didn't have and I when
I would call them they would take my
calls and when I would ask them
questions they would always take the
time to give me answers and over the
course of time they became my mentors
like they became my friends and I
remember one time I was with one of my
mentors Ron Bruder an amazing guy and I
was leaving his house and I put my arm
around him I said you know I'm glad
you're my mentor and he looked at me and
he said I'm glad you're mine and it
caught me completely Lee off guard and
true mentorship like true friendship is
not a one-way street it's not about one
person only giving advice to the other
both people are showing up to give and
both people are showing up uh to learn
um but you can't ask someone to be your
Mentor especially someone who's a total
stranger knock on their door and say
will you be my mentor if they don't know
you and you've never met them it's like
friendship you cultivate a relationship
and if that person is always there for
you and wants to see you thrive and
succeed and believes in you then perhaps
they will become your Mentor like making
a friend let's say there's one person
who started their own little business a
little consultancy right got my shingle
out I'm a consultant right and
everywhere they go they keep telling you
that they're better than everyone else
uh they keep telling you they're smarter
than everyone else they keep telling you
that you know the big the problem with
the big companies is is they don't have
the flexibility I'm it actually gets to
the point of being annoying to the point
that we don't want to actually work with
them because we don't believe them right
um because
um now let's let's change the change the
scenario you meet that same person and
and they introduce themselves look
there's a lot of good good Consultants
out there
um some of them are a lot better than me
um but I wake up every single day to be
a better version of what I do today than
I did yesterday and I can tell you the
device I give today is even better than
it was yesterday and the advice I'm
going to give tomorrow is even better
because for me it's an education and
that's why I love working with
open-minded wonderful clients who are
partners because what we end up doing is
growing together
right now that's one person think about
how appealing that person is they've
actually told you that you may actually
get as good or better advice somewhere
else but it's who they are and who
they're being in the disposition that
they bring that make them way more
trustworthy and uh us wanting to work
with them
um and it's the same for big companies
it's got nothing to do with the size of
the company which is it's called
humility and honesty I remember young in
my career I experienced this myself when
I when I went off and hung my shingle
out and I was a little I had a little
marketing company a little marketing
consultancy I remember going into
meetings and the client would say we
want you to do all of this for us and
I'd say I'm really good at that pretty
good at that okay at that really bad at
that I highly recommend you hire
somebody else to do that and I'm happily
partner with them for them to do that
and the clients wanted to work with me
more
not even though I just told them I can't
do that only because I was the only one
who was honest everybody else they talk
to big or small told them that they were
great at everything which is just not
true nobody's great at everything and uh
and so it's amazing when you take the
risk to be honest it pays dividends and
the trust that you build be the leader
you wish you had become a student of
leadership study it read about it watch
things about it practice it every day
you know like be a parent you know like
join the movement means I'm going to
take care of my team sometimes I'm in a
leader leadership position and sometimes
I'm not and it doesn't matter I'm going
to practice leadership if I'm a
salesperson you know if I'm if I work at
the if I work at uh the check Encounter
of an airline I'm going to take care of
the people I work with I'm going to take
care of the customers as if as if
they're my family you know like practice
leadership learn about it study it
um because I do these things because I
recognize I'm just a piece of a jigsaw
puzzle you know it's one of the reasons
I wanted to come talk to you on camera
it's because you know when we do a
jigsaw so the first thing you do is lean
the picture the the Box against the wall
and then you start putting the pieces
together to build that picture my job in
this movement I'm the guy who points at
the box right I'm the one who's pointing
at the picture pointing at the picture
maybe pointing out a couple of the
pieces and where they go but I need
lots of people to join me we need lots
of people to join us who say I have a
piece of the puzzle I'm willing to lead
this way I'm willing to abandon Milton
Friedman ideals and and do something
bigger something more follow that you
know live with an infinite mindset lead
with an infinite mindset
um and put their piece down and say how
can I help build that Vision we we need
the Army and so how people can engage in
the movement is actually practicing all
the stuff more than anything else that's
what we need the tension is healthy the
tension is good
um you know if all you have is empathy
then you have a hippie commune and
you're not actually going to cure
anything but if all you're doing is
driving the numbers driving the numbers
uh you're gonna have a short lifespan
and break the machine also and you might
have a spike and then you'll disappear
or all your best people say I I hate it
here and they go work somewhere else and
take all of their their their their
Brilliance somewhere else
um so you there is a balance but there's
all also a hierarchy you know it's not
50 50. there's no such thing as 50 50.
it doesn't exist you can't say well
we're 50 driven by performance and 50
driven by culture because you will face
decisions we're one of those things has
to SAC will sacrifice the other the
which one the question is which one are
you going to choose there has to be a
bias towards people there has to be a
bias towards uh the teamwork the
environment
um and the will to to to succeed is
driven by the belief in the cause
um uh uh you know if if if the cause is
clear and the metrics and you're letting
people see the metric so they feel they
feel like we're making progress again go
back to that Marathon analogy right
which is you're exhausted you're tired
but you're getting close to the Finish
Line you start running faster not slower
that's a good point
um uh and so uh it's it's it's keeping
people included to know what the metrics
mean and um and which ones are trending
and which ones are absolute but yeah
there's nothing wrong with the drive to
succeed as long as there's a context
within which uh within which that drive
exists when we are willing to put
ourselves at risk to be there for
someone right don't worry if this goes
south I will be there for you
um which may mean working late it may
mean working extra hours it may be
putting our reputations on the line I
mean there's a lot of things that that
takes
um but when we genuinely promise to be
there for someone
um
um uh and and it has to be genuine uh
because if it gets tested it's it's very
easy to find out if it was genuine or
not
um but if it's genuine then then it's
repaid remarkably let me give you a
silly example
um let's say that um so I talk about
this um sometimes which is the giving of
time and energy is more powerful than
the giving of money you can't build
trust with money so paying somebody
bonuses and giving somebody a big salary
though feels nice is not earning or
building any trust whatsoever you cannot
pay for trust
um and here's the example
um let's say you're moving house
um and one of your friends says you know
what I want to help you we've been
friends for years
um I'm gonna pay for the moving van
here's five thousand dollars and the
moving van let me know how it goes have
a great move that's really generous
right
another friend says you know what I want
to help you move and they come over the
week before and they're sitting in your
house packing boxes they're
sweat dripping down their brow they're
there with you all day they're there to
help load the truck they're there to
help unload the truck they're they're
there
um uh to unwrap everything right they
paid zero money
they give you time and energy which are
non-redeemable Commodities money we make
money we spend money we make money back
it's a redeemable commodity time and
energy are non-redeemable Commodities
and so when someone gives us something
that they cannot get back
it has a much more powerful effect on
how we feel so now both those people
call you another time and say I need
your help which one are you more apt to
help you want to give you money or the
one who gave you time and energy and
that this this is a good lesson for
leadership as well giving our time and
energy is often more powerful than
simply just throwing money at someone
you have to be clear and open about what
you stand for and just like when you
hire somebody
you want to make sure that when you hire
them that they share your values that
they believe in your vision you know
they don't just think it's corny you
know or marketing
um but rather that they they buy into it
and sometimes we'll make mistakes and
sometimes people will come and they fall
in love with it after the fact but we
it's you know we try on balance to bring
people that we believe will get along
with the people who work here because of
our values and our and our cause and so
too is it with with with suppliers
um I think that um uh or or clients it's
the same thing which is we stand for
what we stand for and our goal is to
attract people who believe what we
believe the the more vocal we are about
what we believe those people literally
will come to us or turn down a
competitor who may even be cheaper
because they would rather do business
with us and so it's okay to do business
with a supplier that doesn't believe
what we believe but we have to go in
with eyes open knowing full well that
this is just a transaction you offer a
decent product you give me a decent
price this is not going to be a lifelong
relationship this is a transactional
relationship
and when it's done I'm just going to
hold you to very different standards
right because when it's transactional
we're a little less patient when things
go wrong
um
and sometimes we kid ourselves you just
can't do that too often it's like if
you're living a healthy lifestyle you
can have chocolate cake just not too
often
um so yeah I think the more vocal you
are the more you attract and then you
have to make decisions like you're
hiring people because they're going to
become a member of your family as well
this is the difference between the
short-term finite minded and the
long-term infinite minded the
finite-minded is it the cheapest today
is it the best relationship today and
pay no attention to the secondary or
tertiary effects and definitely pay no
attention to what will happen in five
years whereas that long-term minded
infinite-minded uh player
um looks at some it's it's looks at
something and and looks at someone and
says well you know you're not the
cheapest but I think we're going to get
along just fine and over the course of
time the quality of work will far away
what have you paid a friend of mine
who's a consultant loves to joke about
her clients that they never have the
time or money to do it right the first
time but they always have the time and
money to do it again
and I think when you're infinite minded
you consider those factors from the from
the beginning we Bandy these words
around a little too quickly these days
they all kind of mean the same thing you
know authenticity and tension you know
purpose flow all these things you know
of course it matters what is the what is
the birth of this motivation is it for
PR is it is it to hire Millennials
because that's what they want so we'll
give it to them you know uh uh is it is
it because the street demands it or is
it is it because it's something I
fundamentally believe in I'm I'm very
for with the Roundtable announced the
statement's a bit pablum but you know it
reads like a you know the generic values
that put on the wall of a generic
company
um uh I would have liked to have seen
them the people who they attribute the
work to in the press release to folks
like Kip Tyndall from Container Store or
Jim Senegal from Costco who've been
leading this way for decades and have
been outspoken about the way business
has been done and been criticized for it
for decades like they're better
Messengers for it because they're deeply
they have that deep intention they
fundamentally believe business should be
done this way and the true
infinite-minded player
wants to build a business not just to
Build a Better Business for themselves
it's they want to build a business
because they want to build business
better so they don't just come up with
an idea and then hoard it they come up
with idea and share it because it's good
for the game it's about perpetuating the
game so if the intention is to see All
Ships rise then then I'm very open to
what these these companies are saying if
the intention is to see our ship rise I
become a little cynical the best leaders
are actually the best followers in what
ways what do you mean
um the best leaders never think that
they're the final that the buck stops
with them they always believe that
they're in service to something bigger
than themselves and even if that leader
uh the person in leadership position
gets to the tippy top of whatever
organization they still feel that
they're subordinate to something even
bigger right so uh uh the Pope
this still thinks that he's in service
to something bigger than than him right
a CEO of a Visionary organization
feels that they are still beholden to
and in and following a vision bigger
than them so the best leader is actually
the best follower is even if they're at
the highest levels of the organization
they're still in service right it may
not be to a person but to a cause
whatever it is there's still some sort
of something that they're beholden to
and they're devoted to and they're in
service to
um so so followership is a thing
um and
um not to belabor the Marine point but
uh you know Marines when they evaluate
their leaders they're looking good for
good leadership and good followership so
for example there when you go through
OCS officer candidates uh School
selection
um uh
uh when somebody's a for a task you know
chosen to be the leader of that group
for that task the the Marines are
watching the others as well so they're
looking to see that everybody's
contributing ideas and they're looking
to see that that leader takes in those
ideas but is decisive and and they're
looking to see that the the members of
the group if their idea isn't picked
they still give their all
to see that that the leader's idea is
successful and if it fails give it their
all to pick up the pieces and and see
what they can do as opposed to going I
told you right should have gone my way
right I was right or sabotaging because
their idea didn't get picked so they go
all in so so good followership is is as
important as good leadership that that
we we respect that that
um when a decision is made we will we
will give our Blood Sweat and Tears to
see that the decision our leaders have
made will be successful and if it fails
we will help pick up the pieces because
that's the deal what I think is really
interesting is think of a date like uh
uh like a job interview right
um and think of a job interview like a
date right so um if you went on a on a
first date with someone and they sat
down they said you know
um
I'm extremely rich
um I've made lots of money I do lots of
cool things I've met a lot of famous
people
um I go on TV all the time which is good
because I'm really good looking uh yeah
yeah would you want to go on a second
date with them right not very appealing
it's also not very appealing when we sit
down for a job interview and just tell
people how great we are and all the
things that we've done it's the same
kind of thing now imagine if you knew
you or why and you're making a
conversation with someone uh and they
say so you know where are you from would
you know tell me a little bit about you
and you say you know
I love what I do I love my life I love
my job you can say I I I wake up every
day to inspire people to do the things
that Inspire them and for me the
challenge is finding all the different
ways that I could do it
um and I've been really really grateful
for the path that it's taken me and I've
I've made some money and I've got to go
on TV which is fun because I'm really
good looking and you can see how all the
same jokes and all the same things now
have a context and that's what why it
does it provides context it also helps
you connect with somebody that when
somebody's telling you about themselves
and you ask some questions and you get
to know them a little bit and you
realize that maybe their values are
completely different than yours so y
gives you Clarity and confidence in who
you are and what you need around you but
it also helps you present yourself in a
way that's way more authentic now
there's a there's a there's a rub to the
why that I don't talk about that often
um uh because you really have to get
good at giving your why before you can
deal with this but the the difficult
part about knowing your why is the thing
that you give to the world the value you
give and offer refer to other people is
also the thing you need the most
so it's one so one of the ways to to to
to
um understand the people in our lives
partners and Mates is can they actually
give us the thing that we give to other
people
because of the organization obviously
um uh it's very common
um that other team members will go to
the leader and say we don't want to work
with that person I mean that that's
usually a big highlight you know
um uh that's frequent
um uh you can tell in meetings very
often if somebody is domineering
um but I'm also a great fan of peer
reviews quite frankly
um uh the the Army Rangers dealt with
this they called them Spotlight Rangers
when when candidates were going through
Ranger school
um they had to in the past they had this
issue where these very talented Ranger
candidates and the T and the instructors
loved them so they looked like they were
great candidates the problem is as soon
as the spotlight was turned off
they were horrible people so leadership
didn't know
and so they implemented peer reviews so
now you have to be good at your job your
instructor has to like you and your
colleagues have to like you you're
you're you're and so
um and by like I mean respect and you're
you know you you're seen as a team
player and help each other out so um if
all you're doing is reviewing annually
someone's performance
that's insufficient there needs to be
regular feedback mechanisms and there
needs to be an open open dialogue and
peer review 360 review where you all
come into a room and you get to give
each other feedback in real time
um but yeah it's probably because there
aren't enough metrics
so leadership and Authority are not the
same thing
title affords you Authority affords you
rank right but that doesn't make you a
leader I know many people who sit at
high levels of organizations who are not
leaders
um we do is they tell us because they
have authority over us
but we don't trust them and wouldn't
follow them anywhere
um and we I know many people at low
levels of organizations that have no
formal rank no formal Authority but
they've made the choice to look after
the person to the left of them and and
take care of the person to the right of
them and we would trust them and follow
them anywhere
um and so rank affords you the
opportunity to lead at scale
it affords you with the opportunity to
take care of more people Implement
systems and and incentive structures and
all the rest of it and reward behaviors
to to to to to you can influence culture
with rank but that doesn't make you a
leader and you still have to study the
the the the the tenets of leadership and
and and when they align it's magical you
know when you have Rank and you and
you've been studying leadership then you
can then you can actually affect the
culture in a in a more robust way and
and one of the primary responsibilities
of any leader is to make more leaders
and and you can do that at scale if you
have authority what is your advice for
somebody that's in a company that they
they don't have an infinite minded
culture don't don't be there no don't
try and influence that which you cannot
influence don't control that which you
cannot control you know an infinite
mindset means
that is something I can do but I can
influence and take care of the people to
the left of me and to the right of me I
can take care of the people who work for
me I can even take care of the person I
work for sometimes we have a toxic boss
not because they're bad but because we
don't understand the pressure they're
under sometimes to Simply exhibit
empathy to our boss you know hey boss
you were really harsh on us today
everything all right what's going on I'm
worried about you you know I'm here like
we can we can succeed together I'm we're
here to help you you know if we're no
matter where we are inside an
organization leadership is not about
rank or authority leadership is taking
responsibility for the people around us
and so any anybody on any team at any
rank at any level can be a leader the
first choice is that we have to want to
be a dear friend of mine Lieutenant
General George Flynn from the Marine
Corps said that the first Criterion to
being leaders you have to want to be one
um so any of us can volunteer to be a
leader
um and that's what you do you commit
yourself to seeing that the people with
whom we work on a daily basis love
coming to work they feel that someone's
got their back they feel supported they
feel that they have top cover they feel
someone cares about them as a human
being listens to them knows their story
allows them to be themselves we can be
that leader and what you start to see is
those teams becomes really high
performing those teams become super
tight and you start to hear rumors
across the company because everybody
wants into that team because apparently
it's a great team to work with to work
on
um and before you know one of those
people goes and moves to another team
and they take everything that they learn
because leadership is learned and they
do it for another team and if we take
that infinite mindset
and eventually the tail will Wag the Dog
and it doesn't matter if it's this CEO
or another CEO because we will Outlast
whoever's in charge right now and that's
the goal we're doing this for the good
of the organization we're doing this for
the good of the Cause right and the tail
can whack the dog
well one thing make them work together
um uh I shared in sentence is also a
part of thing usually all we do is give
individual incentives which means we're
only incentivizing Behavior to work
individually
um
uh and by the way incentives don't
always have to be Financial it can be
just recognition and reward you know
catch people doing things right so when
you see people helping each other and
sharing call it out publicly you know
complement publicly criticized privately
um uh in front of the rest of the team
um um give people promotions when
there's a behavior that you want to
promote like like teaming
um but also ask people to solve problems
together and and thank them together and
if one person comes to you and complains
I'm doing all the work you say well why
don't you find out what maybe they're
struggling maybe they're like we have to
push push back
um uh and also I think the most
important thing is leading by example
um asking for help I mean when the
leader acts like they know everything
and they have all the answers then all
it's doing is telling everybody else you
better know everything and have all the
answers because that's how you're going
to get ahead here and so I think one of
the most difficult things for anybody in
a leadership position to get comfortable
with is is saying I don't know or I need
help or can somebody help me or can you
do this with me
um I love working I love teaming with
folks on on my team it doesn't matter
what the rank structure is bringing
someone Junior let's work together
even if all they're doing is poking
holes you know do you think this is good
no I think it can be better okay let me
try again
um so I think I think demonstrating the
behavior that we want is a big part of
it if I ask you do you need to change
and you said to me no I'd be worried you
know like you think you figured
everything out like emotionally
professionally all your relationships
everything's golden okay how's that
working out for you you know I think the
answer is always yes which is to view
ourselves or our organization patients
as Works in progress you know that is an
infinite mindset infinite mindset is
fundamentally constant Improvement
so you know there's big change there's
little change there's tweaks there's
dramatic change sometimes it's reacting
to changing cultures uh changes in
culture politics technology you know
sometimes the change is our own
sometimes we have to react to it but I
think the honest answer is yes we have
to change there's always opportunity to
improve something
thank you
so there's this notion in businesses
that people fear change which is just
fundamentally not true people fear
Sudden Change you know
um but incremental change is not
threatening people feel fear change that
threatens them right and very often the
way we change manage uh is we do lots of
PowerPoint presentations about what's
coming and don't worry and we have all
these things and we we treat it very
rationally and what we're ignoring is
the emotional response now there are
some people who who love change
um yeah it's a it's an infinite minded
thing to embrace uncertainty to see
opportunity in surprise for some people
especially people who have been who have
gotten good at doing something for 10
years 20 years
um that all of a sudden you'd say you're
gonna change it they fear again there's
that emotional word they fear that
um they won't know how to or it will set
them back and so no number of rational
assurances will help them get over that
at some point we have to just let them
go through the process the biggest hack
to stop caring about other people's
opinions who stop living other people's
version of your life and to start
actually feeling happy and proud of
yourself the biggest hack to doing that
is to figure out what you stand for to
figure out your single most important
core value I believe that everybody has
a single most important core value and
when you figure that out it gives you a
lot more clarity a lot more Direction a
lot more confidence and allows you to
start to to do things that you never
thought were possible all of a sudden
that idea that you've gotta oh my gosh I
could do this thing but then never take
an action on it things start to happen
for you because you have that Clarity of
value so I wrote two books on this your
one word and built to serve and we go
through the process of figuring out your
one word or your who who are you what do
you stand for what is that single most
important core value
one of my favorite activities that I go
through I call it the five essential
questions but the most important one
there I find usually is asking people
who is your favorite teacher growing up
and why
so if you've understood the concept of
hey I need I need to have a core value I
need to know what I stand for I'm tired
of being on on quicksand I'm tired of
living other people's version of my life
okay great how do I figure it out do I
just pick one at random do I just you
read a book like how do I actually
figure out what I stand for well
asking yourself that question who your
favorite teacher growing up was and why
I think it's critical think about it
you've had how many teachers in your
life think about your school elementary
school high school uh University if you
went to a college other teachers you've
had
you've had lots of teachers growing up
and
chances are most of your teachers if you
walk past them on a street corner you
wouldn't recognize them That's how
little of an impact they've had on you
think about your high school teachers if
they walk past you right now you
wouldn't know who they were
because they had no impact
but there's always that one teacher that
stood out
there's one teacher that stood out for
you
why it wasn't because they taught you
grade 8 math
is because they made you feel different
as a human
they gave you something more than just a
subject matter they were teaching
and that gives you a clue why did you
like that teacher gives you a clue as to
who you are and what you want to spread
into other people so quick example my
favorite teacher growing up was Madame
Farr but I'm far was my grade 12 French
teacher and I didn't love her because
she taught me French I barely use French
and on a day-to-day basis
what she taught me was to believe in
myself
I was a BNC student going into my last
year of of uh
and she would meet with me every week
before before school started once a week
we'd sit down we'd chat we'd talk about
life we talk about
school we talked about where I was at we
talked about what was on my mind
and in those conversations she made me
feel like I could I could do more that I
that her belief in me created more
belief in myself
and in that last year I went from being
a b and c student to straight 90s
straight A Plus
[Music]
I was still the same guy I still had the
same ability and the same Talent you
know she wasn't passing me the answers
to the test that I had
it was just that belief in me that she
gave me that allowed me to go off and
start to perform more
so I think that's the most important
question you can ask
another one you can look at is what was
your favorite movie growing up and why
what's your favorite movie of all time
why there's so many movies that you've
watched most of them you don't remember
but there's one that that sticks out
that really stands out for you in some
in some way for some reason my favorite
movie is Seabiscuit it's about this
horse that is way too small it's about
this jockey that's way too big it's
about this owner that's bankrupt and
somehow they all find each other and
start winning a whole bunch of races
when when they they shouldn't be you
know and it's based off of a true story
and it ended up lifting a nation that
people love this Underdog Story and it's
a story of belief same thing
a story of belief
we all at least for me I love the idea
of being that Seabiscuit or being the
jockey or being the owner
and helping not just each other believe
in themselves but also the nation for
the audience for the fans helping them
believe in themselves
and so if you started asking those
questions if you started thinking about
who are the people that make you come
alive that make you feel like you're a
better person and what are the resources
or what are the YouTube channels or
Instagram accounts or books or podcasts
or shows what are the things that have
made you come alive what are the things
that have made you feel
like you could do more
and then next to each one write down a
couple of words so your favorite teacher
growing up who was it and then why three
words to explain why your favorite movie
of all time
and then three words why and what you'll
find is as you do this exercise
you'll see some similar patterns you'll
see some words pop off the page you'll
see that same word come up a couple
times
that's your who
that's your single most important core
value
that's what you still need more of in
your life right now and that's what you
want to give to the world
the other great part about it is that
will be with you for life this isn't
something that we want to change this is
who you are this is your best version of
you
at my core I'm I'm the best when I
believe in myself and my biggest problem
is still I need to believe in myself
more to get to the next level
when you figure out your most important
core value your who your one word
know what you need right now
my biggest challenge right now is that I
don't believe in myself to hit the next
level
and it's what you want to give to the
people around you if you're watching
this you're probably an entrepreneur you
want to you want to give to the world
you want to have a big mission you have
a big message
but some people like Nina who is just
here she doesn't have a big message but
she wants to help the closest people to
her
we all want to feel like what we do
matters we all want to feel like we're
having an impact on people whether the
closest people to us or to the world
but we're stuck and we're lost and we
need guidance and if you feel like you
have all these ideas but you don't know
how they all make sense
and you don't know that
you feel like it could be something but
you don't know how to get there
there's not enough momentum happening
is because you're not in touch with your
single most important core value
here's an example
if I'm struggling to do something I'm
struggling to get on stage to speak I'm
struggling to turn on the camera to make
a video for you I'm struggling to launch
my next project you know I get an idea
and then I say oh but I can't do that
what do I need
at the end of the day what I really need
like what's the thing that's going to
turn that idea into actual action
I do more belief
and so when I can catch myself
procrastinating finding excuses saying
no when I shouldn't be I can quickly
reverse it by saying Evan you need to
believe more in yourself
because that's at the core of who I am
and when I can catch it then it gives me
the courage to go off and do it to
record the video to get on stage she
launch that project to say yes to say
yes to say yes I think of uh Alex who
helps me run Toronto dance salsa his who
is belong
he needs to belong more with himself and
he needs to spread more belong to the
world
and whenever he's not happy and whenever
he's not following through and whenever
he's not he hitting his goals and doing
the work is because he doesn't feel like
he belongs doesn't feel like he belongs
to himself and he doesn't feel like he's
spreading belong to the world if you are
stuck
you are going too slow
if you have all of this unrealized
potential inside you
thing that is missing
is you not following through on who you
say you want to be you're not matching
that potential
how you make it practical
to figure out your who
because every time you come back to that
and say I just need more of X I need
more hope I need more freedom I need
more belief I need more belong I need
more love I need more care for myself
and then to spread it to the world
and when you can feel that
when you can actually
it'll dramatically change how you show
up
all of a sudden now you're making
progress where you weren't before you're
accomplishing more in a day than you
were in a year
chains you've given yourself wings
you've given yourself the permission to
actually go off and do the scary thing
that's inside you because now you know
who you are
figure out your one word figure out your
who
watch your life change
[Music]
it's far in a video I want to celebrate
you most people start and don't finish
most people never actually follow
through most people say they want
something but they don't ever do the
work to actually get it but you're
different you are special believe Nation
you made it here all the way to the end
and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome to learn
how to get rich in the new economy check
the video right there next to me I think
you'll love it continue to believe and
I'll see you there right now the entire
economy is shifted the last century was
a century about power and when I say
power I mean like energy the wealthiest
individuals of the last century were
built on oil the biggest companies were
all energy companies fast forward today